okay folks seeing that it is 1pm i am
going to reconvene the continuation of
the
subcommittee work session for senate
bills 367 relative to the regulatory
status of advanced recycling and
manufacturing facilities
it is now open
uh before we begin i'd like to also then
just
make a note to folks
that we do have a hard stop of 2 p.m as
there is another hearing immediately
following
so
with that i had distributed
um to the members of the subcommittee
work group
suggestions offered
and in
in color as well as we had seen it
previously
and i will
open the floor to my committee
subcommittee members to
ask the relevant questions that they may
representative
thank you madam chair and uh to the
audience and i'm sure
someone will be able to or possibly
attempt these questions i have a few
um
we talked about waste reduction for new
hampshire because that's one of the
goals that we're aiming for and we
have a percentage that we need to
decrease
um
by
with that being said
you know in understanding the type of
recyclables that are going in as
feedstock
it would appear to me and i could have
this wrong
that
new hampshire could never supply a plant
with enough feedstock from its own
sources so my question is
and i know this is a very subjective
question
what percentage
would have to come in from other states
and with that percentage of recyclables
coming into from other states what is
the waste that is going to go back into
new hampshire landfills that otherwise
would not be going in there
and if anyone could answer that i'd
yeah feel free to come up state your
name and
yep
like i said it's a very subjective
question
there you go thank you um for the record
my name is jody grimblets and i work
with the american chemistry council um i
think that's a really good question but
it's a really like you said it's it's a
it's an unknown right now um
do we know the size of the facility that
would come into new england and
potentially look at new hampshire as a
place to be we don't know that at this
point in time um so you know do we think
that new hampshire would be able to you
know satisfy all of its needs it's going
to depend on what size a facility is
actually being contemplated here
i will note that in the legislation
one of the issues that was discussed in
the senate which i think is towards the
end of the bill
is that new hampshire be given new
hampshire's
waste or plastic polymers post use would
be con given like first consideration so
that we're we're using our own um
materials before we look elsewhere to um
to other states
so unfortunately i don't have an answer
because the bill is looking just to set
the regulatory parameters but i don't
know yet what the case use will be or
the situation that could come to new
hampshire
uh thank you um
when it says will be given consideration
that doesn't mean that they have to take
it
is that correct correct and one of the
um i did have a request from another
member of the legislature representative
spang came to the initial hearing and
she asked about the thought of changing
the word consideration to priority i
don't think that's a concern for us i
leave that to this committee to consider
but i did tell her i would bring that to
your attention i think she also brought
one question that i did have that i feel
has still
perhaps gone unanswered is just at what
level of confidence
you folks have that
this sourcing for this
plastic feedstock
would
come to you fairly free of
contamination what the contamination
levels of acceptable
feedstock would be
and i did notice in what you offered up
that you had noticed uh that you had
mentioned
that any materials brought in for
processing but rejected as not
appropriate shall be transferred or
disposed of in accordance with existing
solid waste regulations
um so to that end
what
have you enumerated what the rejection
process would be um no i don't know if
maybe can i bring craig cookson out sure
um
i think also one of the other thoughts
here's my my thought if it's if it's not
coming if it's coming from an
out-of-state um
feedstock provider hannaford and and in
a massachusetts store if it's not up to
spec then perhaps it goes back to the
hannaford store in massachusetts it may
just go back to
yeah i think the the key thing
is that this is a very
highly technological process
so they specifically monitor just as you
would if you were again i use this uh
excuse me this analogy last week if
you're a bakery and you get and you're
making cupcakes and brownies and cookies
and other things and you get eggs in
that don't meet your specification the
eggs are old they're rotten they don't
taste good
they're going to send those back number
one and they're probably going to stop
doing business with that generator as
well so the key thing is remember these
are plastics that these facilities are
paying for because the process is
monetized along the value chain so they
are going to have a tight specification
that because this is an alchemy right so
what comes in the door has to be managed
now if they do send something back i
think the the purpose of that um
provision in the bill that or that we
mentioned would be dealt with within
context of solid waste laws just as any
manufacturer has to comply with any sort
of by-product that it produces and make
sure that it responsibly disposes of
something these facilities would too so
in other words that's saying that these
facilities aren't disposable sites you
know i mean they can only use what they
thank you and what um if i may ask a
follow-up what
assurance do you have from those folks
who are sending
these items to you that nothing
hazardous has been housed in any of the
feedstock or
any of those things that could
potentially pose a risk
in the feedstock once it were
processed into that
um
using syllosis or any of those other
things yeah that's a good question uh so
number one is again as a business if
they're they're not gonna pay for
something that's going to cause them a
problem that's i think number one and
most important because anything
hazardous or that poses a challenge they
have to manage in some way it's either
going to you know it could get and
contaminate the oil and then they don't
have a product that they can sell to a
downstream customer or number two they
have to manage it and then pay somebody
to take it off their hands so from a
business sense they are uniquely
um and very much uh incented to make
sure that they cause they test
everything that comes in the door and if
they again a very high-tech product
process where they're constantly testing
the product they produce testing um
every throughout the system they know if
different contaminants and they can
trace that back to whoever might have
provided that so there's those controls
but in addition to that specifically in
the bill in the in the definition of
post-use polymers which is the feedstock
for these facilities we specifically say
that the feedstocks cannot be mixed with
solid waste or hazardous waste so their
controls actually in the text of the
legislation as well that prohibit that
and does that
one one more does that also include any
plastics that may be derived from
medical sort of sources we are seeing a
huge array of different plastics in the
medical industry so i'm curious to know
how and if you're regulating that
and in in which ways you would be
accepting or not accepting some of those
materials yeah so a lot of sort of the
red bag um
sort of
medical materials are regulated as
hazardous waste so those would be at
this point kind of prohibited at being
used as a feed stock unless you know new
hampshire for some reason made an
but basic plastic stuff that let's say
uh you know a wrap that you know when
someone is unwrapping a sanitary
something in a doctor's office that
plastic could be used but not the red
oh yes thank you i just wanted to make
sure that those on the subcommittee had
a chance to ask rep bixby yeah so
um continuing on with the pro
continuing on with the process of
uh how the
uh the plastic gets from the plastic
producer whether it's a hannaford or
whether it's a
i say it's a transfer station
uh is that
generally done by an ancillary business
that sell would do the sorting and then
sell to the
uh
advanced recycler recycler or is that
on or would that be another branch of
the advanced recycler or would that
sorting happen at the advanced recycler
yeah that's a good question we're kind
of seeing both right now is
um
so number one is if you're getting a
sort of just plastic film from a
hannaford that is
clean and pristine so that would likely
go direct to the facility however
if there is a
transfer facility or a materials
recovery facility that's sorting
plastics from other plastics and metal
and glass
we're finding that facilities are
wanting there to be an extra step in
there to pre-process that into a more
consistent feed because they're looking
at different types of resins there's a
company called cyclix
that has
investment from
and partnerships with pretty much of all
of our members
exxon mobil uh lion del basel chevron
phillips dao um
america styrenics um
several uh this i could give you a whole
list of companies that have signed up so
cyclix's business model is they want to
be more of the aggregator of plastics
and then process it so that it's a more
consistent feed so they can do it um
in higher volumes
they can make a consistent feed and then
they can also sort of pass those cost
savings on to the buyers of that
feedstock this is really a good example
in houston i think i talked about that
last week
houston has partnered um one
sort of waste hauler company um exxon
and liondell the city of houston as well
as cyclics have all partnered together
to really try to source a lot more of
these non-recycled plastics
out of the waste stream to be used as a
as a
feedstock for advanced recycling and i
and before i keep going um i just i i'm
sorry because i just dove in here but
just i know there's some new folks here
today uh just i'm craig cookson i'm the
senior director of plastic
sustainability at the american chemistry
council
i said this last week it's always great
to be back in new hampshire i'm actually
a new hampshire native i was born in
keene new hampshire and my father worked
at kingsbury corporation for 27 years
and my mother worked at
keene state college for a long time as
well in the president's office so always
great to be back here even though it's a
little tougher getting up here today
um
one follow-up and then representative
comtois and then representative kaplan
so uh for the purposes of um
one of the this one thing that this
build does is it changes the definition
of
the
plastic feedstock from being solid waste
to
um
to being uh essentially a
manufacturing feed stock
and one thing that's not clear in the
bill is where
where in that where in the process that
happens and i think that one thing we
may we we would like to see is more
specificity that
uh
it is that it only ceases to be solid
waste once it has gone through that
final sorting process to make it
i think is that something was that
consistent with i would suggest that the
the question i believe is for
yeah i mean
if it intrinsically if it has value
right which people are paying for it's
it's not a waste right right now i think
that's really the big difference is
solid waste is something that doesn't
have any value because it's you know
it's it's um it's garbage basically
right so you're either you're being
somebody is being paid to take it off
your hands to either you know burying a
landfill or combust
as energy here there's monetary value in
the plastics and people are paying for
them so after you
after they have been and this is and i
think you've asked this question uh
representative bixby is
after the plastics have been sorted from
other plastics and other
metals at a materials recovery facility
most states do treat that as no longer a
waste right because now you have a
commodity that has value right so in new
hampshire
when you sort out your number one and
number two bottles and those are sold
into the markets and those are very
competitive right now i mean these are
going for uh maybe five hundred dollars
a ton your high density polyethylene
milk jugs are at like three thousand
dollars a ton right now very valuable um
that's no longer treated as a waste by
most states because of they've been
sorted from the waste stream at that
point
quick follow-up so is it but in new
hampshire is it not the case that that's
are they considered still a waste
product in new hampshire
it's kind of unclear which is one of the
reasons why we want to make sure that
it's it's clear in state statute for
companies to to come here to invest
they're going to want to make sure that
that
the feed stock that they're getting is
not classified as solid waste
would you be able to forward us some
statute from other states where that you
think would be a good model for
making that distinction between reuse
no longer waste and uh you know so that
we can figure out how to put that
separation into our language
because i'm not sure that what you have
in the in the
amendment is proposed does that sure
i i would say that most
most if not
i don't want to say all because there's
always exceptions but most states
regulate the facilities that have
received a
sorted kind of gradable commodity as a
manufacturer not as a as a waste
facility but i don't know i'd have to
look to see
in-state statute where it says you know
at you know this time you know along the
chain it's no longer a waste but it's
generally accepted that if you're buying
a
a plastic or paper or cardboard or
aluminum or whatever it is that that at
that point you're no longer you know
you're paying for it as a
as a valuable commodity it's no longer a
waste and you're a manufacturer because
you're taking it and upgrading into
represent bixby if you look at the
definition of posters polymer where
we're defining that
product
in e
it mentions all the pieces that have to
go into that posters polymer the plastic
is processed at an advanced recycling
facility or held at such facility prior
to processing
um and it's been plastic it's been
sorted from solid waste so doesn't that
definition kind of give you that that
blip in time of when that becomes
the thing i threw out in the trash
versus now it's
meets the a b c d and e and now it's
separate wouldn't that be the
distinction
because that wouldn't be what i just
put in my trash that's going to the
landfill right i just like to remind
folks that the questions come through
the show so
thank you
um i'm
i'll have to take another look at that
representative combo and then
representative kaplan thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question
and listening to
all of this because it's another plastic
that can be used as feedstock does this
put more
regulations on folks
where they have recycling where they'll
have to separate even more has that
happened in other states i guess my
question
no and and i think the
the the
the hope for as this sort of
kind of continues to mature
it's actually it takes financial
pressure off communities because right
now here's a good example i had a greek
salad from your cafeteria seven second
week in a row and uh i was in a little
bit of a little behind today so
we got it to go and the chicken came in
this uh foam container right now this
foam container
is a waste in new hampshire if you throw
it in the recycling bin it's not gonna
get recycled it's called wish cycling so
it's likely to go in the garbage and
then you're gonna have to a community
concord is going to have to pay somebody
to
take it off their hands right
imagine if we have the demand so that
this becomes instead of a cost
a revenue stream to the community
because somebody wants this so it
actually opens up new opportunity for
communities to turn what right now is a
yes
yeah so i guess my question is is unless
residue we'll just put put it that way
um
it's would be unacceptable in your
facility but what you're saying is
there's another aggregator that's going
to be going through and doing a
cleansing process on all of this is that
correct
yeah so one of the benefits of advanced
recycling
and i think we have this written in the
definition of post-use polymers as well
is it can handle some residues now they
don't want to have a lot of residue
right because anything that isn't
plastic plastic is carbon and hydrogen
atoms um doesn't necessarily convert to
this end product that you want it to
there would be sort of a there are
oftentimes a little bit of a
pre-processing step where this doesn't
go in sort of like this they're going to
shred it up this is foam so they might
densify it a little bit and then they
melt it before going in the system and
they might drag a magnet over it just to
make sure there's no fugitive metals
going in as well
you know every now and then you might
have a
you know
a random chunk of metal or something
thrown in somehow that uh you know so so
there's so there are a few sort of
little process steps beforehand um but
yeah this you wouldn't see this kind of
going down a conveyor into the system
this would be long chipped up and
densified
and we have some good videos that we
could send along um insider i did a
video on a company called braven and
you'll actually see
the plastic and it's actually this kind
of like
big sort of densified chunks of plastic
going in so you know again you don't see
like these and different types of
products
again and i want to
i want to be sorry to keep on jumping in
but i want to just make the stress the
point again is that this is just
you know diametrically the opposite
of the way we handle garbage right now
right i mean we just tip garbage
directly in the landfill after we've dug
a hole and we covered with dirt or this
just gets thrown into a combustor and
you know it's
essentially combusted to turn into
electricity this is a much
much more
sophisticated process um from from kind
of soup to nuts
i had i will recognize you in one second
i just had a question along those lines
uh
relative to miss grimbolus's um
testimony where you had mentioned that
perhaps
rejected materials might be then
returned to their source location
have you had any conversation with
stakeholders around that if items were
getting returned what the legality would
be if something was
not up to spec or not up to snuff how
does that then if if
if that were potentially something you
said no this is a hazardous material or
it doesn't whatever um what is that
process
same with any sort of uh business
arrangement there'd be a contract that
both sides likely a legally binding
contract over the laws of you know under
the laws of new hampshire that would
both that would bind both parties to the
agreement
so
the feedstock provider would say we will
provide plastic meeting this spec at
this time in these quantities and the
buyer the advanced recycling facility
would say okay you're to provide me with
this plastic meeting this spec at this
price and then of course there'd be
terms in that contract about what
happens
so likely it would either be sent back
to the generator and say this did not
meet our spec you keep it and deal with
it or
if the cost was incurred on the advanced
recycler to dispose of that off spec
then that cost would be borne by the
supplier so it'd be it depends on the
contract
thank you and then the one other thing
that i had a question on was with regard
to the new edition in here where we were
talking about
uh let me go back to where that is
yes so it's the green purpose for the
purposes of this chapter the products of
advanced recycling do not include
hydrocarbons which are sold or marketed
as fuel for energy
so i i was thinking back to the previous
testimonies as well where you had stated
that there are some portions of this
that might go back into the process and
be used to fuel
itself is that correct the uh the
process that's would these two things be
in conflict with one another
no they wouldn't so
this is talking about let's say as
the purpose of this is as new hampshire
wants to see this turned into feedstock
so this
polystyrene is actually a really
interesting one you can take this and
actually using these processes break it
down into styrene monomer and then it
can go right back into polystyrene
production again like fully circular a
lot of cool innovation going on in
polystyrene
so that would count for new hampshire's
recycling rate right
however if you take this and let's say
they turned it into a fuel it would not
count as recycling for new hampshire so
that i think that's what we're trying to
make sure
is that that these facilities are not
producing
fuels and then counting that as
recycling
you know recycling is turning back into
a product and i think we felt like the
legislation based on the products um has
that pretty well covered but um you know
uh we this is kind of extra comfort i
think in the in the language
thank you representative kaplan
yeah thank you chair for taking my
question and thank you mr cookson uh
we've been talking about these
aggregator facilities that seem to be
necessary for the feedstock to be clean
going into an advanced recycling
facility the aggregator facility itself
is not an advanced recycling facility is
that correct
right and and so they wouldn't fall
under the regulations of this
bill they would likely still be listed
they would be regulated as a kind of a
materials recovery facility um under
your laws here in new hampshire okay
because they're not doing advanced
recycling
and my second question is uh
concerning the fuel and you mentioned
polystyrene
and we got to list one of your plants or
one of the remember plants out in oregon
does this process polystyrene to styrene
and
we received information that that plant
is also you know
one of the byproducts is some hazardous
waste including like lead and cadmium
and stuff like that
if they're following the procedures that
you're that you're talking about how is
this hazardous waste getting produced
and is it getting produced in the
product itself the styrene or is it in
the emissions
so
first of all
not 100 certain on you know they're so
let me first say that there's a lot of
kind of
um
accusations i think against these
companies that are not based on sound
science or actually anybody that has
visited a commercially operating plant
right
a lot of it is based on
you know
very very old data
or laboratory studies so you'll find
that in several reports you know
anti-advanced recycling reports
agilex has got a great partnership with
the state of oregon um we can look into
what you say but these facilities are
not receiving
lead and i forget what the other thing
you said was
you know number one that's not in
plastics um number two
every
bit of polystyrene every ounce that they
receive in the door right now gets
turned into styrene monomer and they
have off-take with they have actually a
joint venture with a company called
america styrenics
that has very aggressive goals about
making sure that this in the future is
made from
representative
in that agilex facility just as a
additional point of clarification sorry
to interrupt um i've been there probably
10 times over the last 10 years it's in
oregon so i usually go once a year but
i've seen their evolution
as a company um going from a a batch
process that made sort of a synthetic
crude oil
that was sold to a refiner to now sort
of retrofitting that process into one
that does polystyrene to styrene monomer
they also draw a lot of their
energy from
hydroelectric so it is an electric
facility up there that is uh very green
thank you representative homeless thank
you
thank you sir um i had a question about
the language in the amendment should i
direct that to you
or to you all
to all okay um
at the end in regulation of advanced
recycling 149 m62 i'm just curious why
this one last sentence was scratched out
the department may enter and inspect any
advanced recycling facility can you
yes
the language that is not stricken in
that
that number one that roman numeral
number one is the language that we had
worked with the department of
environmental services on in the senate
committee um it was language that
they had helped us draft
the language that is stricken we had
actually worked off of a draft that
represented bixby had given to us um and
that was language that and we've talked
about that he had put in there and i
sent a note to represent this be saying
we did take that sentence out because we
had made agreements with the department
of environmental services and we felt
uncomfortable
on unraveling that
agreement that was made in the senate so
the
two sentences before that also still has
the department may enter and it's
inspect any advanced recycling facility
determine whether storage materials
prior etc etc so that that sort of enter
and inspect provision is still in there
and if i could have followed
um the question i also had is that uh on
the first page let me get down to the
right line i don't have lines in mind
apologize but
under the new paragraph different
definitions of advanced recycling a
little bit ways down there's a strikeout
but are not limited to
what is the basis for striking that out
i think there was a a
request to be more specific
that the products of advanced recycling
here in new hampshire are going into um
commodity products or raw materials that
go into recycling markets and there was
concern that sort of an unlimited may
lead the door open to fuels so we wanted
to clarify that this is the intent is
absolutely thank you um lastly the lead
paragraph the lead two paragraphs going
into that was that something off of a
suggestion by you all or was that was
the the findings and purpose and then
the purpose of this chapter the first
so i
was concerned that it was not clear from
the bill as it as it was presented that
um
that the
uh
these facilities would be
regulated under manufacturing it would
be subject to all of the manufacturing
regulations
and i wanted to have uh have it laid out
in the
in a preamble essentially saying that
uh there were
there are
regulations that these uh that these
busines that these
uh facilities will be subject to uh that
are not
that are not part of the um
the the bill itself uh that are exist in
other parts in statute and um i think
this gets
moves in the right direction i'm not
sure it's got it it's all the way there
but um
and uh as for your question about the
line that i put in and that was then
removed because it didn't match what
they had gotten from director wims at
um
my intent with putting that line in was
to make sure that
uh des in their
clean air and water divisions
would have the capacity to inspect at
any time they needed to in order to
ensure compliance etc
the issue may be
that it is
not that the language
not the language itself but it would be
putting it into
a solid waste part of the statute and i
think we need to uh get
is there any from anyone from uh des
here
yeah um
so uh
i'm maybe would you be able to clarify
in terms of whether that that's just in
the wrong place or is uh or is there
already language in every clean water
and air statute that says there's
the department can enter for
inspection and compliance ensuring
compliance
actually if you don't mind i'd actually
like the department to come forward to
be heard at the microphone
you're welcome to sit it yes any of the
good afternoon mike fitzgerald i'm the
assistant director of the air resources
division at the department of
environmental services
director wimsatz not able to attend
today he did indicate to me that he had
i don't think the department took a
position relative to the
to the bill but we did not have any
objections and he had no concerns with
this language that was shared with us
yesterday
um
so uh
relative to uh
almost all of our statutes i i cannot
speak specifically to the way statutes
but
in general stat the statutes do give us
the authority to uh
to enter in to inspect facilities um
to determine compliance with with the
applicable statutes i can i can speak
specifically we do have authority under
rsa 125c and 125
i
um 125c is our general air pollution
regulations and 125i is our toxics um
and uh we we certainly have authority to
conduct inspections um
and to uh to enforce those um uh
the authorities that are given to us in
in those statutes uh so
i i i don't think that there's any major
concern
uh this this strikeout language it
happens to have reference to aaron water
and it's in a way statute
um
i i assume that ols will take a look at
it and and uh
um
you know if they if they feel that it
causes a conflict but uh as i say uh we
we received this yesterday afternoon
took a took a brief look at it and and
didn't see any concerns with with taking
it out because i think we feel we have
the the authority that we need
um specifically in the waste authority
that's in the two sentences above that
were referenced
um
uh but uh um
including it would not be problematic
yes so
when a manufacturing facility is coming
into the state of new hampshire
do they are they
are is there a requirement a statute
that they consult with you about
anything that they are going to going to
be
working doing
as a manufacturer well speaking
specifically from the air permitting
side
companies are responsible to determine
whether they are subject to
the
ensuing regulations um
uh enva 1400 for instance would be would
be the toxics regulation
so companies have a responsibility what
generally happens is when a
company plans to come into new hampshire
they will make an appointment and come
in and meet with with our department
and
once we have an
understanding of what they plan to do we
will have representatives from the
appropriate divisions
that would have some responsibility as
as part of that meeting
but in general uh a facility has a
responsibility if they're subject to our
permitting regulations they have to
submit an application and receive a
permit
and if they're subject to the toxic
regulations they have to do the
appropriate determinations to see if
they're emitting those those toxics
and
report to us
provide modeling that shows
how much the emissions
uh
you know the quantity of emissions that
would would go out and if that quantity
exceeds the
uh thresholds that are established in
our regulation as i mentioned the other
day there's 700 some odd um compounds
that are that are covered by that
regulation
and um we would make a determination as
to whether they were subject to uh
permitting and
um and any of our other regulations
so
it's it's a combination the company has
a responsibility under those statutes to
make a determination and if they're if
they're subject to our regulation to
submit the appropriate requirements if
we find out about them
and they have not done so they would be
subject to
you know
certainly significant enforcement
actions
thank you
thank you mr fitzgerald may i ask a
question as well um sure thank you um so
my question to you would be you had
previously testified this is a
relatively new territory for the
department yes and uh i guess with that
i was curious to know whether or not you
would have had an opportunity elsewhere
to tour a facility or to see any other
facilities that are out there in
operation
uh the only
in my experience the only facility that
i'm aware of that we've had had any
contact with is um and i'm forgetting
the name of it now but there's a there
was a facility that came to us last year
up in
groveton i believe
and
we did meet with them we took a look at
their process i don't know if we toured
the facility i don't believe it was
built
at that time
and
we made a determination that um with
regards to uh air toxics and air
emissions that it was a closed loop
facility and was not subject
to our requirements
we did understand that they intended to
use one of the products
that they produced as a fuel for a
diesel generator on site
they subsequently came to us and
indicated that they were just going to
use diesel fuel and so we permitted that
facility
we do permit emergency generators as
well and we permitted that in the way we
that we would do so for any any facility
such as the one that you can
see in the parking lot across the street
here um
you know and
uh it's it's the only fuel that can be
used on in that is diesel fuel so if
they decide to
make a change to that they would have to
come to us and revise that permit
representative stapleton
thank you for taking my question sure
it sounds like that
when a advanced recycler comes to you
they're going to have to pretty much
deliver you
a business plan or a production plan or
whatever you like to call it both
upstream
sourcing of materials in specifics
and the downstream products is is that a
correct uh assumption of what uh and
that's on that basis you're going to
make determinations yeah in general from
from an air perspective which is where
my experience is
um we would sit down with a facility we
would
expect them to provide us with um
technical information plans etc
that would demonstrate
uh and quantify
um
feed products and
ultimately
emissions to the air
products that they make
may or may not be regulated
depending on
um
you know this statute makes make some uh
or this
proposed legislation makes some
uh assumptions as to as to how those
products would be
would be handled i would also point out
that certain products
fuel products
that are produced from processes like
this could be subject to federal
regulation
have these but um fuels are regulated by
epa and have to be registered depending
on their
on their use
i can certainly send the committee some
some information relative to epa's fuel
registration process and so on and
there's also what are known as
non-hazardous secondary material
regulations which
um
uh epa as i think we testified last week
uh epa is currently
um taking a look uh at at this and has
put out information requesting i put out
a a request for information
from companies that are planning to do
this type of process
to provide information and comment on
how epa
should or should not address
these these facilities and the products
from these facilities under those
non-hazardous secondary materials rules
so that's the subject of current federal
dialogue and input right now
but
so
we may not regulate those products
except as 149 m
already
states but there could be federal
regulation as well
but then in general we would
look at all this information that's
provided
we would sit down with them we may ask
questions we may ask them to provide
additional information etc and then
uh as as i mentioned with this facility
up north we we made a determination that
they were not subject to 149c or 140 i
mean 125c or 125i
uh except for that diesel generator and
so uh if if a facility came in met with
us
we would certainly
so
before you issue the permit for them to
proceed uh does this get uh written up
in a rather detailed
extensive contract sort of a document so
each one can
each side knows what they're going to do
and you can regulate and monitor
according to what's written in a
specific document well i've never heard
of it referred that specific way but
that's actually a pretty good uh
pretty appropriate that's what a permit
is when we issue a permit that permit
tells the facility
it specifies the processes that they
will use it specifies the emissions they
must meet it specifies the testing that
they must do to to determine
those emissions and that is a legal
and enforceable document for us that um
so that if we go and inspect them and
they're doing
uh they're not
it would have record-keeping provisions
it would have testing provisions etc
that's all available online we always
issu when we issue a permit we issue a
public notice of that permit we have a
30-day comment period we hold a public
hearing in this town where the facility
is located
and we receive any public input on that
and then we
we may incorporate
if we receive information from the
public or from some other source and
we would incorporate that those
revisions into the permit we would issue
that permit
and if it is a federal permit because we
do have some responsibility for for
issuing permits under title v
so if the facility is large enough and
meets the criteria to require a federal
permit that permit would then be um
uh
forwarded to epa and they we would issue
the permit but epa would um
again
take a look at it and they would provide
us comment if they wanted any changes to
make it federally enforceable um but in
general we would do the issuing of the
permit and and we would enforce the
federal side of that permit as well
thank you very much
thank you i think i i have another
question
for you folks at the acc um
so with regard to new paragraph number
five where it's
uh
e
where the sentence reads the plastic is
processed at an advanced recycling
facility or held at such facility prior
to processing
i i did have some questions sort of
about um i've seen various sort of
circumstances where the bales of the
plastic product that are coming in are
held inside some are held outside and i
guess i wanted to
just talk about you know is this stuff
being held prior to it being washed
potentially holding remnants of previous
uh
things on it and if it would be sitting
outside and it's exposed to the weather
would there be a chance of potentially
that's
those things
the plastic degradation or
items sort of run off sort of running
out or if it's inside i mean that's
that's an area that it gives me some
pause yeah a materials recovery facility
where they're sorting plastic from metal
from paper from glass they might store
plastic bales outside
but i don't know of any
advanced recycling facility that would
store plastics outside um and there's a
important reason for that is
um is number one is is any sort of
moisture
contamination just water
you know uses more energy right it makes
the process less efficient
and so you know one of the key steps in
in um sort of as i mentioned from a
pre-processing standpoint is plastics
like this would come in and then you'd
shred them then you might densify them
and then melt them so you get a
consistent flow in so any water
contamination on this
actually you know that water has to
essentially cook off right so use energy
so it makes the process less efficient
and at the end of the day what these
facilities are trying to do is make sure
that every molecule they can goes into a
saleable product
so i don't know of any facilities i
visited
i was kind of counting them up on the
way i think i visited nine
different advanced recyclers over the
course the last
nine ten years in both the u.s and
canada i don't i don't think i've ever
seen any that have stored so they're
plastics outside they all storm inside
thank you
representative bixby do you have a
question yes um it's actually a question
in that same paragraph
in
line
two
at
letter b
uh it is not mixed with solid waste or
hazardous waste on site or during
processing so when is on-site does that
mean at the
um
at the advanced recycling facility yeah
it's intended to mean within the fence
line of the advanced recycler
so uh so essentially
uh
any sorting from
uh materials that would
not qualify as feedstock would have to
happen before it was on at the at the
facility site
yeah because your sorting facilities
would be regulated as materials recovery
facilities under the solid waste laws in
new hampshire these facilities are not
sorting right they're receiving uh
plastic that's been sorted already okay
so i i think that um i i understand that
line now but i think we might need to
amend it in order to make it clearer
since it wasn't entirely clear
representative kaplan and then i think
we're going to have to sort of make a
decision as a subcommittee as to where
we would like to potentially go
yes a question for um
for mr uh goodson cookson cookson
cookson
um is there anywhere in the in this
proposed legislation that uh would
determine the ultimate use of the
feedstock i don't see anything saying
that it can't be used as a fuel for
instance
you mentioned that you know the the goal
is to create a saleable product and
because there's you know it's it's a
business but i mean
there's nothing our interest is is is
different from your interest our
interest is to reduce recycling as it
says in the preamble now um
to reduce the amount going into the
waste room and increase the recycling so
the intended use is a fuel uh for say a
you know chemical or you know any kind
of a cement kiln for instance something
like that that really does not help our
cause at all it might help you it might
help the businesses uh interest so is
there anything in this regulation that
says
uh this is intended as a feedstock for
recycling into uh plastic products not
fuel or anything like that yeah i
believe in the in the definition of
advanced recycling um was that the
second sentence where it says recycled
products produced at advanced recycling
facilities include
um and we eliminate the but are not
limited to monomers oligomers plastics
plastics and chemical feedstocks basic
and unfinished chemicals waxes
lubricants and coatings so all products
of chemistry some of those are more
finished products like a wax
or a coating
and some of those are intermediates or
raw materials like plastic and chemical
feedstocks
okay i was looking at uh the line uh on
section five e i think it was
uh
that's uh oh yeah the plastics sorry
this section c the plastics use or
intended use is as a feedstock for the
manufacturing of plastic and chemical
feedstocks
other raw materials or other
intermediate products or final products
using advanced recycling
the way i read that that could include
fuels
i i think we're covered from sort of the
new addition to again back to the
definition of advanced recycling on the
first page for the purposes of this
chapter the products of advanced
recycling do not include hydrocarbons
which are solder market as fuels for
energy
representative clemson and then i think
representative pearl might have a few
things
thank you madam chair um just a quick
question on the words coding
and lubricant could that be oil
um could you use it for oil
not as a fuel like a coating is
something that goes into like paint is a
good example it's a product of chemistry
um
which you know if we can get that from
recycled products instead of you know
virgin
feedstocks like natural gas or oil
that's a good thing right we're
displacing that use of
a virgin product and then same thing
with a lubricant a lubricant
is like something that's in your car
engine you know that make sure that the
you know the engine doesn't overheat
then you have problems so um but it can
representative pearl
thank you madam chair it's fun sitting
over on this side
well just for the benefit of the
subcommittee um you're not forced into
making a recommendation this afternoon
because what i would like to do
is have you
have an opportunity to take the
information which you've been having a
great conversation and
i certainly appreciate all of the work
here with the subcommittee and everyone
that's come along
and
you've had the opportunity to get some
good and useful feedback on the
questions that you've had so
i think the process that we're going to
do is we'll next tuesday we will
schedule a brief subcommittee meeting
but all i'm going to give you time for
is to come in have a quick discussion
like 15 minutes and come out with a
recommendation that will then go to the
full committee if that gives you some
clarity on on the process going forward
that's fair mr chair
all right so
i just will remind you we have a hard
gamble in at 2 p.m on the next hearing
so you're going to have to wrap up in
about four or five minutes
i would like to recognize the individual
sitting at the back with their hand up
uh feel free to come forward if you
yep
my name is john tuthill i'm from akworth
i testified at the original hearing i
just wanted to note that on the house
calendar today this was noticed as a
continued public hearing
um
is that is that what this is a public
hearing or a work session no no
okay that that is actually on the build
docket for um
for sb 367. it's noticed as a continued
but notice that that we're seeing here
it says subcommittee work session 1pm
yeah well i'm looking at it online and
that's what comes up on your house
anyway i'm not going to belabor the
point um
however i did hear some things today
that concerned me i'm not going to
comment on them now and perhaps we'll do
that in writing or speaking to
one point that really stands out however
if you do go to groveton new hampshire
you will see
extraordinary amounts of plastic stored
outdoors
i've been following that pilot project
for years the ones we're seeing across
the united states the nine or ten that
have been mentioned some of them really
have been seriously
um
i i just think they've had a hard time
bringing these things up to any kind of
an industrial level or scale so i hope
that new hampshire will wait until epa
has really delved into this and i think
we're several years from being ready for
a bill like this thank you very much
thank you
representative bixby yeah so um
this is a question for the subcommittee
and the question is basically
do
does the subcommittee think at this
point
that
it would be possible to pull together an
amendment for next week and um
uh representative homeland and then i'll
recognize representative oh sorry
i was just thank you chair i was going
to just say that i um i don't have any
issues with the the
meat of the amendment i do have a bit of
an issue with the
preamble to it because i believe that
what the purpose the first sentence of
the second paragraph encapsulates
everything that this needs to be
and i that's just kind of my only
comment
thank you
any further comments from the
subcommittee
just comment that um if the subcommittee
does come up with
further amendments if you could possibly
share those with us that
we'd be happy to take a look at them and
see if there was any concerns
so i think i i think in that given that
we have literally four minutes left i i
will continue it again for the
subcommittee work session to be held
next
let's just give us one second here to
you just hang tight we'll confirm a time
that way we're
apologizing
madam chair just just so you're aware
next week is new hampshire spring break
week that may affect
okay so with that then we'd like to
um continue
until the 26th
with a time to be determined
so
yeah
um
i'm just so
what i
got from uh chairman pearl was that
uh
that there's going to be a very short
amount of time to work on this next week
so if there is going to be if things
need to be further amended
then that work needs to be done this
coming week and my personal feeling is
that although i've done a fair amount of
work on the process so far that it
should be a member of the subcommittee
who is doing the final
amendment so i just want to make sure
that
there is some sense among the
subcommittee about whether the intent is
at this point to come up with an
amendment for next week or
say that we don't have we we're not
that's a fair um
that's a third conversation i do
um
sure
thank you madam chair um for me
i'm not quite there yet
i still have questions and i still have
some concerns
um
and it revolves around our solid waste
policy not necessarily the actual bill
about how this will actually affect uh
recycling and reducing our waste in new
yes representative homaloff i was just
going to answer thank you representative
bixby's question i'm i'm comfortable
with it i would like to to see an
amendment
uh finalized amendment and move forward
just in case you're taking a poll on
that
okay
i was going to say i i wouldn't mind
despite the assurances from the ds i
wouldn't mind seeing the original
language that was in the senate bill uh
around the regulatory framework be
reinserted you know
that's just my feeling about it
i think the intent is for the
subcommittee to work on this and we'll
see where we go with this and if we have
an agreeable uh amendment available for
next week so with that is the intention
to work on it
is it a recess that this would be in
i can close this out then thank you and
then it will be continued next week
on the 26th thank you thank you
[Music]
all right welcome everyone it is 2 p.m
and
welcome back to environment and
agriculture
we're going to
reopen the hearing on senate bill 368
relative to the unlicensed sale of live
animals in establishing the agricultural
hearings officer revolving fund
this is a bill that we recessed last
week
so i currently have one more pink card
and that is uh so we'll call stacy ober
welcome to the ena committee
turn your mic on
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee my name is stacy ober i am
the new england government relations
contact for the american kennel club
american kennel club is a 135 year old
not-for-profit organization that
represents 5 000 clubs across the
country and
has 14 affiliated clubs here in new
hampshire we're a recognized expert in
canine health training breeding and
responsible
dog ownership
i want to first just acknowledge that
akc and new hampshire dogs has
consistently
reached out to work collaboratively with
the department of agriculture
to assist with enforcing the pet vendor
licensure laws
and that we are grateful for the
department's commitment to enforcing its
provisions
when senate 368 was introduced we did
have a lengthy conference call to hear
from the department what problems they
were needing to solve relative to
what was explained as two
individuals that were transferring pets
without a license
post revocation of their license for
violations of the act
and
we do appreciate that at the hearing
both the department and the senate
natural resources committee agreed with
akc and new hampshire dogs testimony
that the bill is introduced authorizing
the seizure by the department of animals
senate bill 368 as amended and coming
accomplishes two things and we are
concerned with them which is why i want
to speak with you today
it would increase subsequent violations
up to five thousand dollars for any
violation of the chapter by any pet
vendor so it's not specific to
anyone whose license had been revoked
and is now transferring
without a license
in the testimony last week
it was stated that the department had
not fined up to the maximum dollar
amount of a thousand dollar fine that's
allowed in the statute so it's unclear
to us how
increasing it to a five thousand dollar
fine would be useful to the department
if you look at rsa 437
10 which is the penalties section
it makes the unlicensed transfer by a
pet vendor which means someone who's
transferring more than 30 dogs per year
as based on the filing of certificates
of transfer
it constitutes a misdemeanor
and we know the department has expressed
to you all that they're not getting the
assistance they need
to enforce it as a misdemeanor
in our estimation this is an issue with
law enforcement and the doj
because as we look at that section of
the law it appears as though the
department has the tools already in
statute that it needs to enforce the
section
i think the bigger issue i wanted to
uh revisit was in testimony
that
is not addressed in senate 368
is that
the department was apparently tipped off
about an individual who is transferring
pets with no veterinary exam and
therefore no
health certificate of transfer at all
resulting in a complete end around of
the law with no consequences
in our estimation senate 368 should be
amended to fix that problem now not next
year otherwise we're spending a lot of
time figuring out how to penalize those
who are selling healthy pets that have a
health certificate of transfer but are
doing it without a state license while
others are selling pets of unknown
health status without a license and no
penalty for it
with regard to the second part of the
bill and establishing a revolving fund
to hire hearing officers if eliminating
the exorbitant fines of five thousand
dollars there is less of a risk of
conflict of interest and we
recognize that
we do believe the department should have
an established amount of money needed to
do the job each year preferably through
the state budget
i did do some research hearing at the
department of j of doj
their resources are strapped as well it
looks as though in fiscal year 2020 and
in the budget for doj there was a line
item of just over 2 million dollars
with 3 000 to train contracted legal
counsel to perform these tasks i don't
see it in this current biennial budget
but there was a line item there so i
just acknowledged that as
a model that's been used apparently in
the past
so in our estimation we'd like to see
the committee make some amendments to
or send it to study so that we could
further examine what the challenges are
and be certain that
they've been satisfactorily addressed
with a policy that's effective thank you
thank you uh will you take questions
yes are there any questions
seeing none thank you oh did we have one
representative murray
mr chair for taking my question and
thank you
um you had mentioned you had reached out
to the department of justice
is that
no the department of agriculture
oh i'm sorry i thought you made
reference to the department no i
researched the department of justice
budget and that's what i was just
reflecting on that in the fiscal year
2020 2021 budget they have a line item
for contracted council legal counsel uh
was in the amount of two thousand
excuse me two million thirty thousand in
a separate line for the training of
those providers which was three thousand
dollars
thank you
representative dutsy
yes thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question do organizations such
as
your organization or
dogs do any um oversight or regulation
uh pursuant to
your members that
may not have licenses and are selling
dogs
do we do regulation do you have do you
do any oversight do you um you know for
example um
you know we do educate we do a lot of
education for instance we get uh
questions all the time trying to
interpret the law and what's required of
them and i know new hampshire dog spends
an
enormous amount of time matching people
up with someone who may have the same
example or challenge that they're facing
or to explain to them how the law works
and to do that education yes okay
clarify clarification
sure uh not education in other words if
you come across an individual who is not
following the law
do your does your organization or any
other
dog organization in the state
do anything to make sure that
that they no longer can be a part of
your organization that a referral is
made to you know law enforcement sure
um akc has a very large inspections and
compliance department so i'm glad you've
asked because it's something i think
that surprises people they're not aware
of it um when you are affiliated with
the american kennel club register a
litter with the american kennel club you
have volunteered to be arbitrarily
inspected by our department and uh they
will do
random
inspections in addition to
scheduled inspections periodically for
individuals that are registering a large
number of pets and we do have a
care and conditions policy so they will
go in and make sure that the kennel is
complying with the care and conditions
policy if they are not they will issue a
warning and a plan of action and come
back in
a three-month period for instance to
ensure that those things have been
addressed if they're not in those
instances yes they would be referred to
whichever state they're in um
to acknowledge that this is someone that
is
in need of of action in terms of whether
it's a license revocation or
cruelty charges you know anything of
that nature depending on the
any further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
all right that's all the pink cards i
have any uh anyone else wishing to
comment further
all right seeing none so uh before i
close up we'll read the blue sheet
we had no sign-ins on the blue sheet in
person but we had uh nine in favor
online and 43 of 43 opposed
online
and with that we're going to close the
hearing on senate bill 368 and we're
going to actually move into the full
committee work session on senate bill
368.
so we've had
good testimony
here
in the in the hearing and
in between or in the interim i should
say i've had many conversations myself
with
the members of um that have testified as
well as the commissioner you know for on
behalf of the department about uh
perhaps an avenue forward where we could
address the concerns that were raised
here in in testimony and i also did a
consultation with the attorney general's
office on a couple of ideas that had
been presented
especially relating to cease and desist
powers and just just different actions
that we could uh take
for to give the commissioner the tools
and the power he needs
i certainly understand that the
frustration that he has in the
department you know we the legislature
have charged certain duties to his uh to
his department and he feels he's not
meeting them and failing to do so
because he doesn't have the tools
necessary
and so i think that's
one of the key parts of this bill is the
hearing officer will will help him to
to get there and meet at least some
portion of what he feels is on his plate
to do so
that is the wrong paperwork we're not on
that bill anymore let me get to the
right pile there we go
so
i had some conversations with um
representative bixby and representative
aaron and i have certainly kicked around
a couple of ideas and
i've also gone to uh the speaker's
office and the clerk's office to kind of
run through some of the thoughts that i
had on a way we could solve sort of a
middle ground i think that will fix
the majority of what the commissioner is
having for concerns and or for
issues and
also address the majority of the
concerns that we heard in testimony
so i've asked ols to draft up an
amendment and if you've got the senate
bill 368 in front of you
if you look at
under section 1 paragraph two
that is where it uh seeks to raise the
fine from one thousand to five thousand
for consistent violations it's not a
subsequent violation excuse me
the commissioners was in agreement that
we could remove that and leave it at the
current 1 000 rate
he felt that the more important part of
the bill for him the biggest tool was
setting up the revolving fund and
establishing this position of the
hearing officer
so i've asked ols to draft up an
amendment that would eliminate
that section that raises the fines it
will keep the section that uh has the
revolt section two with the revolving
fund in it in addition it will put a cap
of 75 000 a year
that will
that the department can use for that
hearing officer
and what i think that does is i think
that eliminates some of the concern that
was expressed about the possibility of
the department using this as a sort of a
tool to increase revenue if it was
unlimited the more fines that they
issued the more they'd have to use for
the hearing officer so by capping the
fund at least for now at five thousand
dollars i think that will take at least
a great step toward
eliminating that concern of head hunting
or whatever you want to call it for the
department using that as a revenue
source because they're currently
collecting more than 75 000 so
it this would give them no incentive to
collect anything further than they
currently are
additionally we heard concerns from the
department that there were
areas
in in
437 that fell short of allowing them to
enforce
the
any uh unlicensed individual from
transferring an animal without a health
certificate so there was
a mechanism that made it illegal in the
sense that they were subject to a
misdemeanor but there was no real
enforcement action that the department
itself could take because there was no
administrative action authorized within
the statute
because they're not they don't enforce
criminal penalty that had to go either
through the local municipality or
through the department of justice you
know or excuse me the ag's office
so i've asked that an amendment be
drafted to
would include language of
making it a thousand dollar fine
administrative fine that the department
could administer if they find that
someone is transferring without a
license so that would put them on the
same level playing field as say a pet
vendor that's violating the rules
so when this and there's one other
section in 4
8 that we had to do a little bit of
cleanup language too that would
sort of substantiate that and make it so
that the commissioner could do this and
it just required us adding that no
person
excuse me firm corporation or other
entities shall transfer ownership of a
dog cat or ferret without an official
certificate of transfer that just kind
of locks it all together and it gives
the department
an administrative way to deal with this
not just a criminal way
so the one thing that happened when i
did that which i went to the speaker's
office i had a concern that by putting
this new fine in
which is consistent with the current
fines but it's technically a new fine on
a different
section of the public than it is
currently being fined because they're
not pet vendors
because they hadn't violated the pet
vendor statute because they weren't
registered
so that was how they were slipping
through
when i did that i was concerned it would
create a non-german amendment which the
speaker and the clerk agreed so
what i'm going to do is i've had this
i'm having this amendment being drafted
i'm going to
schedule a non-german amendment
hearing for next tuesday
and we will
hear that as a non-german amendment but
we're going to have to hear it and
execute on the same day because we're
getting to our deadline of getting this
done
but that's what i've put forward and i
think this cleans up all of the issues
or
most all of the issues i'm sorry maybe
i've missed something but i ran it again
by representative bixby and
representative aaron to kind of make
sure we were closing all the loops so
with that i'm going to open it up to
representative vicks because i see he
has a comment
yeah so um i have a comment and a
question uh my comment is that i think
it makes a lot of sense to make sure
that there is in fact a
uh
a fine for transferring animals without
a health certificate
slash certificate of transfer and
one thing that i um i
i spent a lot of time working on this
last a couple years ago
and but i don't remember whether the
change of term from health certificate
to
uh official certificate of transferred
happens has already happened or whether
that is something that will happen when
the database is up and running
and we want to make sure that
that
if it if it's currently listed
in law as health certificate but is not
and and will become official certificate
of transfer we want to make sure that
it's covered in both of those situations
appreciate that i'll uh i'll have ols
look into that make sure that we're
using consistent language thanks
anybody else have anything they want to
add or questions or i hope i was
thorough oh yes representative vonsky
thank you mr chair uh i i like the uh
the 75 000 cap and i like
what it does i'm just curious is there a
mechanism available to us
to i guess peg that to inflation or
something where the commissioner's not
going to have to come back every few
years and have the cap raised in order
to be able to afford
to do what he's doing with it now
is there a mechanism available for us or
is that just how it's going to have to
work
i think if we put it in statute that's
how it's going to have to work
we could
i think my suggestion would be let's
let's start there at least for a short
term because the commissioner felt that
this was more than sufficient for what
he'd need at least for the foreseeable
future in my conversations with him i
certainly don't want to speak for the
commissioner if i'm if i'm incorrect in
that certainly feel free to to correct
me but
thank you mr chairman i appreciate the
work that uh you have
have done on this um we don't have a
really great way of knowing whether this
is going to be sufficient
or not but given what we're collecting
in fines felt that this was a way to to
address the concerns representative
pearl and i had a conversation about
actually putting something in the budget
but given that it
was not an early bill there's no
opportunity to do this so this was
perhaps an inelegant solution and
perhaps in the future
the
the way to to to deal with this will be
to budget it and take it out of statute
but to to get the ball rolling this
is uh
i think the way to do it what we've
talked about in the department
is because we don't know when we don't
want to spend
perhaps all the money early on is we
will probably look at some of these
fines that traditionally don't go to a
hearing
continue to handle those in-house to
to moderate that because many of these
are are settled
an informal hearing process i did
um
preside over hearing yesterday and that
is one that clearly would have gone this
way but there are others where you know
the disagreements may be minor and we
can settle so we're going to have to
sort of guess and engage as we go and go
along because the last thing i want to
do is
um is spend that money if if it were to
come to that and then end up with huge
cases that would be a drag on our time
so we're going to have to sort of play
around with this and and see where we
are and what the result is but this
this gives us so much
more ability to to do what the
legislature has asked us to do than
we've ever had before so we're
appreciative of it
thank you well i think we as we kicked
around it kind of
gave us a a opportunity to start the
program and see how it went and how
things worked and then protected
protected the uh you know certainly
provided some protections on the other
side for those that were skeptical as
well that answer your question
okay thank you representative aaron
thank you mr chair and thank you
commissioner for your comments i
am curious to know with this amendment
um that
uh chairman pearl is proposing
how do you see that that may help you
with the current two or three really
large cases that you're dealing with now
well um
maybe not with the with the two or three
one of them is being handled by by the
by the courts but they've asked us to
hold off on the defining end of it
so as to not confuse the two that that's
part of the problem because it is a
two-track system it's not either or
so in this case the police have taken it
as a misdemeanor but we've been dealing
with this for
you know
at least a year at this at this point
since the first arrest was was made
getting close to that anyhow um
so
if we get to that that point
um this would go to a hearing officer
because it takes up so much time i think
as i i told you last week in this one
case we've
we've spent uh over a hundred hours
um now some of that would have been
spent regardless because we're assisting
law enforcement
on that
um but it will definitely hear us uh
allow us to to go out and do more of the
inspections that we've been asked asked
to do and that's the
the bottom line of this is allowing us
thank you for that
anything further representative contra
thank you mr chair um
listening to some of the wording changes
that you are proposing
in the original legislation when we were
discussing we had
some time where you know someone may
sell
30 puppies one year and then less the
other and they would have an exemption
but with this new proposed language
they would be guilty
it's my understanding and i don't know
if your
amendment is taking into consideration
the discussions that we had um
mitigating some of those circumstances
that we had discussed when the original
language were proposed
so i think you're referring to
a bill we put in last year that provided
an exception process
okay so
in that exception process we were never
intending anyone to transfer an animal
without a health certificate that's all
this is addressing what what that
process was doing was providing an
exception from registering as a pet
vendor that this wouldn't impact that in
the least
that is
that's my understanding as well chad
chairman anything further
representative dutsy
uh yes thank you
uh first of all i appreciate all of the
work that you've done on this and i'm
i'm glad that we're going to be moving
it forward
um
i can relate to what the commissioner
uh feels because in the in
the conservation commission we have a
similar issue where when we see
violations we have to refer to code
enforcement
there's not enough people in code
enforcement to work on housing projects
problems let alone anything to do with
the wetlands and we see this over and
over again where violators do egregious
things and we just have to let let them
go
so i really appreciate work secondly
uh do you expect that we will be able to
get the amendment in enough time
are we
going to be getting the amendment prior
to
next week's session so that we can kind
of go over it or what is your time frame
yes you will it's uh in ols currently
being drafted and
i will have to have it
i believe i have to have it in hand
before i can announce it which i should
have before tomorrow noon
and so once i do have it i will
certainly forward it to the committee
for review
representative perez
yeah um i just wanted
something to be clarified um so with
this amendment that you're proposing
that will take the penalties
of a thousand dollars away
uh for the first um
what i'm reading here on the ground bill
is a thousand dollars for the first
violation and five thousand for each so
that
the new amendment that will take that
away no so the new amendment will just
eliminate the change it will stay as it
currently is where they can be fined up
to a thousand dollars
that's currently in statute we just
wouldn't be making a subsequent
violation of
i totally understand that people don't
want to pay you know five thousand
dollars consequence of violation but
i hope and and i would love to see that
if we easing with the you know with the
violation money um
people realize that we're doing
something to try not to have people pay
more than what they need and now
hopefully they respect
what the commission is trying to do and
and all the work that they're putting
into all these cases that they have
going on and they've been having going
on for a while so i i hopefully
we're not hurting what they do and now
okay i i believe from the conversations
the commissioner and i had that we'd be
leaving the current levels of fining in
place and we just wouldn't be elevating
it but representative murray
thank you mr chair for taking my
question thank you commissioner so i
with respect to this conversation of the
two tracks that you have like that are
going on in the conversations about when
something moves forward in a court of
law versus through your hearing officers
um i guess the question that i have is
is there a potentiality for where
fines and
uh judicial fines are imposed on
somebody
and then you uh
you're unable to recover the fines and
is that when it then gets transferred
to the
da's office i'm just trying to
understand i apologize
no that's that's a good question thank
you so the the two tracks are one would
be a misdemeanor
um i think as i said last week i don't
expect that anybody would go to jail
for that but i think the there is a
limit on what you can be fined
for a
uh a misdemeanor so
if somebody went to court and the judge
said
well it's a misdemeanor and the limit
for this misdemeanor is a thousand
dollars
in in the case i was talking about we're
talking over 150
transfers
of animals illegally and the court
if they did not wish to put somebody in
jail
potentially would find them a thousand
dollars
we would then go on with our
case which could fine them up to a
thousand dollars for each
violation
and each transfer is a separate
violation as intended by
by the legislature because you don't
transfer
multiple animals under one health
certificate you have each one
and let me give you an example of how
that that breaks down and when i
proposed the 5000 i was thinking
specifically of that but the hearing
that i had yesterday
the inspectors wrote out 10 separate
incidents
violations but it was one inspection
that one inspection constituted one
violation even though within
areas of concern
so
in that case
the first time would have only been
a thousand dollars now sometimes i think
my inspectors are probably a little bit
too nice and people aren't taking us
seriously because the previous
inspection had also uncovered a number
of violations but essentially they were
just warned but instead of getting
better things actually got worse
and i would have rather that we had
issued a hundred dollar fine
to start with to get their attention
i wouldn't ever want to start out by
finding somebody
a thousand dollars for what are not
egregious things but they're in
violation
and and what we're seeing is in almost
all cases
um when we give a warning nobody's
taking it seriously and we go back and
things have slipped even further but
that's still
representative bixby
yeah this is actually just um pretty uh
for for new members um just a a little
thing about bill reading um which is
that uh
when you have a bill uh
the the um the print that's in ordinary
type is the existing language in the
statute and uh
whatever's in
the bold italic is the
uh is the new language that's being
suggested and if there's something
that's in brackets and struck out that
is part of the original language so um
and that's that's that's just you know
it's not really obvious when you're you
know picking up a bill exactly how that
works
but um that that should help with you
just
well representative stapleton you got in
just under
thank you for taking my question
so
if i read this correctly you're building
in some flexibility but still giving
yourselves the tools that you need to
handle many different type of
circumstances here there's a lot to
cover in this is there not
there certainly is and yes i am trying
to build in
inflexibility and i want everyone to
understand
that
our intent is not to find people our
intent is to bring people into
compliance
but
that's not been working out very well
with the with the gentle hand and that's
why
um
you know we've gotten to these extreme
cases not necessarily because of that
particularly not in the case where we're
seeing you know 150 or more
violations of transferring animals and
those are where we really need the help
but it is amazing just
how many of these would go and as my
inspector told me yesterday
there are cases where they should be
writing letters
um and they they simply can't because if
they spend all their time
writing letters of warning and violation
then they're not going to be doing
inspect inspections on the other
um facilities so you know again this is
about animal health and well
well-being but primarily disease control
that's primarily what this is about and
that was many of the things that i heard
yesterday in the hearing were about lack
of documentation
that
the the vaccinations were given that the
animals were were quarantined had
received everything they want
a lot of these cases we're dealing with
now
are are rescue places we're seeing an
awful lot of animals coming up from the
south
and in order to be properly brought into
the state they need to be quarantined
they need a record of
you know the vaccinations and the
testing and some of that is not being
documented
in some cases
it's sloppy record keeping and the
records may be there but
people need to do a better job when we
go in there
they need to have a file on each animal
that shows what's required by law
and
you know if people would do that it'd be
a lot easier but
unfortunately many of these are
home-based rescues
with people have
really good hearts and they have a few
friends who are joining in with their
with their organization
but they're not following the law is and
good as their intents are and our our
job is not to say well your intent was
was good but you totally
violated the law and therefore it's okay
and frankly that's what a lot of these
people
want us to see and that's why as i've
told you we collect more fines from
weights and measures but that's not an
issue that they're dealing with their
heart strings you know it's not an
emotional issue these animal rescues are
very emotional for these these people
and so it's it's it's difficult and it
tugs at my heart strings too when i
listen to the stories
yeah so
that's where the hearing officers come
in right hands-on and working on many of
these problems to um put some force into
the law and get derive some order out of
this chaotic process
so how many hearing officers
will you have to do this
my hope is that we end up with contracts
with three hearing officers because some
of this is going to back up depending on
the time of year and i'd like to have
um multiple availability of hearing
officers obviously there's a there's a
limit but i don't don't
think we would
you know be able to handle if there was
only one person available because of
some of the seasonality of some of what
we're
we're seeing seeing here so i mean who
knows we'll work on a contract
with doj
and and go out and try to find qualified
people my thought is we may be getting
some
retired lawyers who are just looking for
a little bit of
extra income something to do
um you know i haven't sat down and
looked what other departments do for
qualification certainly
you know what we're doing now is
with with me or another director as a
hearing officer we don't have legal
training so it's a little better than
you know a man on the street but we do
have a set of documents and guidelines
that we have to follow and any hearing
officer could
could do that ultimately it's about how
they see the violation was there a
violation
should they be fined for that violation
one of the things i told one of the
people
the lady yesterday
was that while the health certificate
was not
completely
filled out well the health certificate
that the veterinarian used was
completely
filled out but it was not a proper
health certificate for
the transfer
and i wouldn't expect that a lay person
even though it's in the rules would
necessarily know that there should have
been a line there
for
where was the animal born
and a couple other things
i looked at that certificate and said
every line is filled out and it has
information on it
and those are the type of things that
should i hold that person responsible
well technically yes because it's their
responsibility
but is that really the right thing to do
in this case
we're now doing a better job and have
finally gotten through to the veterinary
association that they need to put out
this form because the law doesn't allow
us to put out a form the law
says what has to be on the form but it's
anything further
all right seeing none thank you
commissioner all right all right i'm
going to close this work session and
we'll let you all know next tuesday and
i'm not sure on time yet we're going to
work and see what our scheduling is but
my anticipation is it'll be mid to late
morning but i will see when the room is
available and we'll get the notice out
to all of you mr chair yes i have one
thing for the committee too i just
wanted to remind you as well i had
gotten an email from anton beckerman
from unh
regarding
an invitation for our committee to come
and see the unh mcfarland research
greenhouse
as they have had open houses
um
and so
he was reaching out to me to find out if
our our committee would be interested
in doing a little field trip uh some
time
let's see he said sometime in the summer
or early fall
when the woodman horticultural farm
would be at its most active
so that our group could get the broadest
sense of their research activities their
farms dairies and greenhouses
and they'd be happy to work
around our committee schedule
to show us what they are doing over
there so i'm putting that out to the
committee and
um
would like to know whether everybody's
interested or not and i can certainly
work on
uh putting something together for us
yeah representative bixby were you
interested or did you have a call
i think that's a great idea and we may
also want to get in touch with rob
gibson at the uh veterinary pathology
lab to uh maybe
uh because he had he had reached out to
me at some point about wanting to be
able to give us a tour there as well uh
it's all sort of in the same general
area so we might want to to do both of
those things at the same time okay
sounds great to me you want to work on
that together we'll pick a date or
something and sure i'll make you to the
all right thank you everyone have a safe
okay
oh
technology
um
you